monkey deffi is now officially one of
the yongo year five has turned him into
one of the strongest characters in the
entire series but to be fair his crew
has also become immensely powerful right
alongside him and it really begs the
question could any of the straw hats
actually beat their captain in a fight
and if they couldn't take down Luffy
individually could they manage it if
they all teamed up together and the very
first crew member we have for Luffy to
fight is Jim baade as we know from
Charlie's fortune telling predictions on
Fishman Island Luffy is actually
destined to destroy Fishman Island one
day and well that probably means that
the Fishman will be returning to the
surface let's say that for the sake of
argument jimbe isn't going to like Luffy
demolishing his hometown and for that
reason jimbe is now going to fight Luffy
and actually jimbe very possibly has one
of the best chances of defeating Luffy
out of anyone in the straw hat crew
after all his speciality is fighting
underwater and Luffy can't move
underwater so if jimbe can use his
fisherman karate to get Luffy off the
ship and into the ocean he basically
wins the last time that Luffy was
submerged he used the voice of all
things to call for help from LW crew and
their submarine but we're going to
assume that there are no submarines
running interference in this fight here
but on the other hand if the fight is
taking place on land then jimbe
basically loses this guaranteed because
yes even though he is a former warlord
he just doesn't have the same level of
immense over powered strength that his
Yono Captain does as a disciplined
fighter he'd probably give Luffy an
excellent fight but he just wouldn't be
able to actually take it all the way I
think but next up Brooke has an
excellent reason to want to face off
against Luffy two in fact firstly Luffy
punched his best friend laboon right in
the face and if he ever found out he'd
probably be in the right to give Luffy a
taste of his own medicine but more
importantly secondly Luffy is just an
awful singer sorry to everyone who loves
the captain's music stylings I guess now
Brook's strength among the crew is
definitely underrated I think he was the
first crew member to wound an actual
yonko or at least their homie and it's
also easy to forget that he's strong on
account that he's never really had a
featured fight in the entire Series so
we're not going to count his opponent on
fisherman Island whom he defeated with
real ease and honestly he probably do
especially well against Luffy
considering that he's a sword wielder
and cutting attacks are after all
Luffy's weakness he can also run on top
of the water while Luffy can't swim so a
battle taking place on the ocean on the
ship might be to Brook's benefit once
again and in addition he could distract
Luffy with certified bangers if he
brings his guitar to the fight as well
however yeah it is Luffy we're talking
about he's unbelievably strong and would
probably break all of Brook's bones
which is all of him and honestly let's
be real it's only a matter of time
really until one day Luffy Hawks all of
the cola on the ship and drinks it
without asking and after that Frankie is
just is going to be real mad and will
take his revenge on the sugary soda
thief and actually cyborg Frankie has
one of the best chances out of the crew
to be able to take down Luffy and it's
not because he's as strong as some other
crew mates more so it's because he has
the shiniest objects to be able to
distract Luffy with as you know Frankie
has a giant mech suit the Frankie Shogun
and every single time without fail that
Frankie Pilots this Mech Luffy just
loses his mind with absolute Wonder and
amazement heck even Frankie's nipplees
turn Luffy's eyes into stars as he Hoots
and hollers at the mechanical marvels of
Frankie in other words can Luffy really
bring himself to destroy something that
he finds so beautiful well yeah yeah
probably yes because Luffy is a
destructive chaotic force of nature that
will break everything in his path if he
needs to good thing I guess that Frankie
is just as good at fixing stuff as he is
at building stuff but up next is Nico
Robin and we'll say that someday once
Luffy fin finally takes his War to the
world government he'll want to smash up
marijua and the red line however Nico
Robin would really like him to preserve
a lot of the historical structures there
so she has to punish him for crimes
against archaeology if you get my vibe
and on the surface Robin has a better
shot than most straw hats just because
she's one of the smartest members of the
crew the only problem is that she just
doesn't have enough raw strength to
actually pose a real threat to Luffy in
other words her fruit is mostly geared
to WS a lot more strategic fighting
which is great to go up against the not
so bright Luffy however her most
Dependable technique is going to be
pretty much useless I mean sure she
could sprout a ton of giant arms and
legs and put him in a hold but she's not
going to be able to use her traditional
clutch technique to break his neck
because well his neck is made out of
rubber it'll Bend no problem at all and
let's be real it's really hard to
imagine the sweet and kind mascot of the
crew chopper ever turning against his
own Captain so in this scenario it's not
going to be about him attacking Luffy
Chopper would only fight Luffy in the
case of self-defense so imagine this the
Thousand Sunny has been a drift for days
the lock pose is lost even Nami can
figure out how to navigate the ship to
safety but worst of all their food is
completely depleted almost all their
food All That Remains is the straw hats
emergency food supply otherwise known as
Tony Tony Chopper and with chopper
ultimate form monster Point only being
barely enough to hold off Queen until
Sanji arrived on the scene he's just not
going to have nowhere near enough raw
power to actually compete with Luffy
however there is one technique that we
haven't seen in a long time that might
be able to help Chopper somewhat at
least which is Brain Points now in case
you forgotten it using his brain Point
transformation Chopper can actually
identify the weaknesses of his opponents
and then hopefully take advantage AG of
them however with Luffy now being as
powerful as he is in gear five it's
really unclear what exactly his weakness
would even be that Chopper would even
remotely be able to exploit however one
final way that Chopper might be able to
win is utilizing his Rumble balls not by
Chopper eating them himself though
instead Chopper might be able to
convince Luffy to try them out by
convincing him that they candy and now
that we know that Luffy is technically a
mythical Zone user by feeding him
several Rumble balls Chopper might be
able to force some unconventional
Transformations as well in other words
if he can get Luffy to turn monster
point the other crew members might have
to stop him from rampaging and
destroying the entire ship which could
in turn give Chopper enough time to
escape and avoid becoming dinner up next
though to face Luffy is none other than
Nami the cat burglar and in this
fictional scenario she'll just be unable
to resist the huge amount of berries on
Luffy's head sadly for the greediest of
the straw heads though there's another
thing that she'll be unable to do and
that's harm Luffy in any meaningful way
now as you know there are of course
plenty of gags throughout the story
where Oda has actually Nami Landing an
effective punch on her stronger
counterparts but that's really all that
is a gag if it really comes down to a
serious fight nami's best weapon is
always to use her climb attack and Zeus
to bring lightning down on opponent and
as we learned from Luffy's fight with NL
that's just not going to work very well
in fact now that he has the ludicrous
Powers off gear five he'll just be able
to grab the lightning and throw it right
back so sorry Nami you're not expanding
your bank account with this one I guess
now with Usopp we actually have a straw
hat that we've already seen fight Luffy
in one of the greatest fights in the
entire series they went head-to-head on
water 7 over the ownership of the going
Mary and after all of that it would be
very very unlikely for Uso to ever want
to face his captain again but for the
sake of argument though let's say say
that while they're approaching L tail
usub contracts a really terrible case of
can't go to that Island disease that he
unfortunately caught from buggy in fact
he doesn't want to go to Left Tails so
badly that he's going to fight his
captain to prevent it from happening but
as you'd expect sadly this is probably
just going to play out just like it did
on water 7 in fact things will be even
worse for Uso because no matter how many
pop greens he has now and even using his
observation hockey they're just not
going to compete with any of Luffy's
gears or any of the three types of
advanced hockey that Luffy also
possesses in other words to give Usopp
any kind of tiny chance to beat Luffy he
would need a whole lot of preparation
since he himself has tapped into
observation hockey he's going to have to
use that paired with his incredible
sniper skills if he even wants any hope
in hell and so we're going to say that
he's found a nice bunch of sea Stone
bullets to put in his slingshot and in
addition he's going to want to fight
Luffy from another Island a few
kilometers away and so if he can get
lucky he might just be able to shoot
Luffy into the ocean with a well-placed
shot but I'm still going to give Luffy
the advantage with those handicaps and
plays because he has really good future
side but next up Sanji is yet another
Straw Hat who has already had a real
matchup against Luffy and he actually
won technically the catch is Luffy
refused to fight back whatsoever and so
if they really clashed something tells
me that it isn't going to go as well
this time now that big mom isn't
threatening the crew though and moreover
Luffy is an emperor himself what would
make Sanji want to fight Luffy in the
first place let's just say I guess that
Luffy hit a woman or in a very unlikely
scenario he didn't finish his dinner
plates so no matter how you slice I mean
kick it I guess this is going to be a
really tough one for Sanji even with his
germa powerups Luffy is far stronger now
to be fair Sanji is potentially faster
than Luffy since he can move too fast to
even be pierced by opponents however
that speed won't really help much when
going up against both Luffy's durability
and future s side and so really there's
only one thing that Sanji is going to be
able to do to even the playing field
somewhat he's going to have to feed
Luffy and distract him with some truly
delicious meat and to be fair I'd say
that Sanji could probably poison Luffy
this way but as we saw in hul Island
using poisons would go against
everything that Sanji stands for and
even if he did Luffy has insane poison
tolerance at this point so yeah no I
think the only thing that Sanji can do
is to cook a meal so satisfying that it
really renders Luffy unconscious which
honestly he probably could so wait a
second does this mean that Sanji
actually has the best chance against
Luffy so far so I guess the only real
question is can Sanji cook a meal large
enough to satisfy Luffy's immense hunger
while they're fighting which means that
before we ask the question if the entire
crew together could take out Luffy we
only only have one straw hat left for
Luffy to face down against so imagine
this the crew is hanging out on Loft
tail having finally made it to the end
of the grand line when suddenly Luffy
hears this s it's pirate Hunter Zoro
finished with the biggest Lan Con in
manga history and he is ready to finally
claim the insane bounty on Luffy's head
now obviously this wouldn't actually
happen because Zoro is the most loyal
guy in all of fiction but we're going to
have fun today seeing exactly what it
would take to bring all of the straw
hats into conflict with Luffy and look
how each of those fights would actually
play out and Zar and Luffy actually have
fought once before all the way back on
Whiskey peak in fact you might not know
this but Oda sensei's editors actually
urged that he would bring these two into
conflict to bring some more excitement
into the story and what resulted was a
wildly outof character moment for Luffy
that a lot of fans hate to this day
however these two have grown a whole lot
since the beginning of the grand line so
how would it play out at the end of the
series well as you'd expect Zoro
probably has the single best chance out
of any of the other straw hats for two
big reasons first because he's straight
up a beast just like Luffy he has access
to all three types of hockey but
secondly it's because his speciality is
Luffy's biggest weakness sorts as you
know Luffy's rubber body can endure all
sorts of blunt objects brw Force even
bullets or cannonballs but he is very
very susceptible to being cut and to be
fair there is no real telling whose
Armament hockey would actually win out
would Luffy be able to block a sword as
powerful as enma with his hockey cated
fist honestly kind of questionable but
one advantage that Luffy does have
though is his future side observation
hockey in fact some people speculate
that he might have even tapped into that
power all the way back during Marine
Ford when he dodged one of mihawk SL
Flash and saved his arms from being cut
clean off and so if Luffy was able to
dodge a slice from zoro's mentor all the
way back before even properly training
his hockey abilities he should be able
to avoid most of zoro's attacks now as
well under the assumption that mihawk
actually was serious at that point which
we don't actually know but honestly even
a transformation like Ashura might not
save Zoro from the chaotic powers that
are gear five as you know Zoro is a
pretty serious noons guy most of the
time and once Luffy tapped into his T
Force I don't really think that Zoro
would be able to handle the absolute
goofiest form of Luffy really if
anything he'd get so frustrated by Luffy
not taking the fight seriously in his
eyes that he'd lose his cool and allow
Luffy to catch him off guards in other
words it would be super super hard and
very unlikely for any of the straw hats
to actually beat Luffy individually
after all he is the captain for a reason
but what if it came down to everyone on
the crew working together to take down
the captain in fact one of the best team
ups in one piece history came when the
entire crew banded together to fight ORS
who ironically did have Luffy's Shadow
but what if they didn't fight his shadow
what if the crew work together to
actually fight the real deal and to
start of this battle we'd probably have
Nami Uso and Chopper running away
probably for Uso that is tactical his
sniping skills are at their strongest
when he can create distance between him
and opponent and who are we kidding
they'll probably all be super scared to
fight someone like Luffy so they go to
hide behind a big boulder while the rest
of the crew starts out the fight and so
on the other hand doing the exact
opposite of running away and launching
straight into action are going to be
Sanji and Zoro however before they even
arrive at Luffy they'd probably crash
into each other and refusing to let the
other be the first one to land a hit on
the captain they break off into a battle
of their own while hurling insults at
each other and yes that sounds Goofy but
you know that's probably what would
happen so therefore that leaves the more
reasonable and mature members of the
crew to start of the fight instead and
in a complete Act of real maturity Brook
starts jamming out on the guitar while
Frankie lets his nipple light shine as
well and gear fight Luffy really can't
stop laughing so his crewmates
entertaining addicts make him go nuts
and making use of this opportunity Nico
Robin uses her M Flur to grab onto
Luffy's Limbs and tie him down to the
ground somewhat immobilizing him and
this barely registers for Luffy who's
still laughing uncontrollably at Frankie
and Brooke and so in a more serious turn
of events now jimbe actually takes this
opening to use a fisherman karate
technique striking Luffy with a huge
surge of water and so the now really wet
Luffy is ready to take things seriously
at least as seriously as gear five Luffy
can get I guess and so using his Tune
Force he spins around like the Tasmanian
devil twisting up Robin's arms and
freeing himself in the process because
yeah yeah let's be real Robin's strength
just isn't going to be enough to hold
Luffy down he spins himself dry and in
the process runs right over the
fisherman Frankie now also getting
serious tries a radical beam but he
swallows it right up just like he did
with kizaru on egad island and he just
gets a bad case of heartburn Brook tries
to attack him with a sore technique but
before he even can the ground becomes a
whole lot bouncier than before and
Brooke is sent flying right into the
boulder that the weakling CH is hiding
behind and so after a lot of screaming
it is finally their chance to try as
well Chopper transforms into monster
point and attempts to holdt Luffy down
giving the others a chance to escape
meanwhile Uso prepares a powerful shot a
crazy spicy Tabasco Star right into
Luffy's mouth unfortunately Luffy's gear
five form can already swallow actual
laser beam so a little bit of hot sauce
is probably nothing however the fire
that then shoots out comically from
Luffy's mouth does cinch Chopper's
beautiful coat of fur and takes out the
reindeer and so in a last Fage effort
Nami unleashes her most powerful attack
courtesy of Zeus and of course fear has
overridden her logical thinking and the
lightning strike does nothing to Luffy's
rubber body and so instead she actually
tries to ride Ze away to safety while
Luffy punches Usopp into the
stratosphere unfortunately knocking him
right into Nami making them kind of
blast off Team Rocket style Luffy laughs
at their Misfortune when suddenly a
powerful flaming leg strikes him right
on top of the head pounding him like a
nail into the ground so Sanji was the
faster of the two pirate King's Wings
after all however Zoro is not far behind
runs in ready to SLI Luffy unfortunately
before he can the ground breaks apart
and both Zoro and Sanji fall into the
chasm where they find a giant gear five
Luffy zaro's powerful strikes slash at
the Giant's legs but thanks to Luffy's
quite powerful Armament hockey they're
just minor Cuts meanwhile Sanji uses his
Skywalk to try and kick at Luffy's head
but both the swordsman and the cook are
quickly scooped up into Luffy's clutches
and holding them there Luffy laughs
proclaiming his victory against his crew
and wishing them better luck in their
next training exercise and honestly even
though it might be controversial I do
think it's no surprise that Luffy would
probably take the win against his entire
crew after all as impressive as it was
zaro could in the end only scratch kaido
while gear five Luffy actually managed
to take down the yonko however as the
crew gets stronger and stronger it does
make you wonder whether someone like
Zoro would be strong enough to take down
someone like kaido or doflamingo on his
own at this point and luckily we
answered that very question in this
video where we talk about what would
happen if Zoro fought all of Luffy's
opponents Shanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one